[Music]  it was a real life scare for Wendy  Williams on Halloween morning we've got  a lot to talk about because the  talk-show host  passed out live on air so it was a lot  of fun let's get started  our first caress the show cut to black  and went to an extra-long commercial  break nearly six minutes long but when  it did come back on Wendy was back up  that was not a stunt  I'm overheated in my costume when I did  pass out but you know what I'm a champ  [Applause]  the show was not that long well thank  you Jerry thank you Dave I love you for  watching today a rep for the 53 year old  tells et Wendy is feeling much better  she overheated because of her heavy  costume makeup and lights  Wendy's rep adds that the host will  address the incident more on her next  show